all right a lot of activity this morning
on the David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum which you can
find at david pakman.com slash read it i
encourage you to join let's go through
some of the interesting discussions and
posts that have popped up on the reddit
discussion forum in the last few days
starting with a very interesting story
about donald trump supporters that were
triggered by the by NPR's twitter
account
merely tweeting out portions of the
Declaration of Independence on the 4th
of July they seem to think that they
were direct attacks on Donald Trump and
what does it say about the guy you
support if merely reading the founding
documents of our country seems like an
attack on the guy you voted for I'd
imagine the supporters didn't even
realize that NPR was tweeting out the
Declaration of Independence they thought
they were tweeting out criticisms of
Trump yeah I mean how embarrassing is
that also discussed on our reddit
discussion forum an interesting post
about whether we should be using
fireworks or not fireworks a big deal on
the 4th of July of course illegal here
in Massachusetts didn't stop two hours
of fireworks but being set off by
amateurs living all around me Pat very
very interesting experience dog amuck
personal you can't get them off it
personally of course official fireworks
displays are allowed but the argument
made by Brody mulligan on the David
Pakman show reddit was that it's really
not good for the environment and for air
quality should we really be doing
fireworks an interesting conversation
that people have participated in also on
our reddit are what is this one this one
I'm having a hard time seeing our show
they okay yes and a very detailed
discussion about when might it be okay
to make Holocaust jokes when is it
considered insensitive are any topics
completely exempt from joking around and
interestingly I think the moderators are
to thank for this but it was actually a
pretty dignified conversation it could
have gone bad it seems as if we develop
some sort of time frame for when it's
acceptable to joke about historical
events yes 9/11 for yeah but if there's
ever an exception to
I think it is when it comes to the
Holocaust particularly when there's
still survivors going on today that's an
interesting point
and I don't know if that particular
point was raised in on the discussion
forum but if it wasn't you could raise
that point also on the David Pakman show
read discussion forum a criticism of the
fact that I sometimes say oh I don't
know oh I don't know I guess when I take
phone calls sometimes I will say like oh
let's take our next call from oh I don't
know maybe the four one three area code
and people pointing that out maybe I'm
saying that too much huh I noticed that
sometimes you'll mock Donald Trump like
you'll see very very alright just use
his sort of language and people
attributed that to you as if that's
actually you speaking right yes and it's
not I'm really just meit's very subtle
mocking of Donald Trump okay so oh I
don't know maybe I'll try to avoid that
and lastly a very specific coffee
question not about whether I've used
david pakman show coffee to try to make
coffe fe but rather do I enjoy cold brew
coffee how do I make it and whether I
use special equipment and I was actually
interested in answering that and I did
indeed answer the question and Pat will
be pleased to know that my vegan cold
brew I will be pleased to make it with
either French press or Chemex
I think both applications are
appropriate for cold brew on the advice
of counsel and invoke my Fifth Amendment
against self-incrimination and
respectfully decline - last thing Pat
ever wants to comment on again on the
show is coffee yeah that it's just done
with it's been bad it's been really
really bad